let's go next to our caller from the 678
area code who's calling today from 678.
hey david that's me at zach from atlanta
zach from atlanta what's going on
listen man it's not looking good for
biden i haven't seen a single
biden harris boat rally in last week
yeah
no you know why all of the boat all of
the biden harris boats are already
underwater the values are huge but
they're just happening underwater
i mean what are your recommendations
providing to capture the vital voting
demographic i mean if you go out there
with a speedo and some ray bans or if
you had any further
you know how can he capture that because
i don't think he's going to win the
electoral college without me
i honestly i have no idea what boaters
how do you appeal to boaters i'm just
not really sure
uh what is it that the boating community
wants what is it the boating community
needs from their leaders
i don't i couldn't tell you one of their
priorities
i mean that's the heart of america right
there so unless he's unless he gets the
ball rolling here pretty quick that's
going to go to trump but it's not going
to be a good time
i would go further i think the yacht
community
is the heart of america not the boat
that you know when you say the boating
community
you've got a lot of dinghies and pontoon
boats you know what i mean that sounds
like riff raff
it's the yachting community that they
need to go after
right right and i know uh there were a
couple of the trump boats at the trump
rally in texas that sank
a few days ago but the whole biden ship
is going to sink
pretty quick it's some it's mariner
metaphors
which we need i think
anyway thanks so much david love your
show just thought i would bring that in
real quick
all right i think that you're making a
very good point and i appreciate you
making it